I'd brag welcome back intrepid Raiders
after braving parts one and two of
gamespot's destiny raid guide it's time
to reap your rewards and make your way
to the final boss of this whole shebang
you're broken into the vault of glass
you've assassinated the Templar and now
it's time to descend into the Gorgons
labyrinth but not without a refreshing
soak first ah once your spa moment is
over just keep descending until you
reach a Ledge overhanging a big drop
nothing to do here really except jump or
get pushed sure you just push them up
guys see I told you we got Sean Metheny
then be sure to use your double jump
close to the bottom so that you don't
die the stream leading towards a red
light is the way forward but you
wouldn't want to leave a loot chest
behind now would you turn around head
back upriver and then make your way up
this cleft in the rock wall jump up the
side of the mountain and clamber into
this cliffside cave it might take a few
tries if your whole fire team is trying
to bozo their way up at the same time
but once you're in just spelunk your way
to the back of the cave to find this
circular door and
crack it open and enjoy the spoils then
be sure to stage a warm welcome for any
party members who are lagging behind
once everyone's looted up get back down
to the crappy little river where you
started and it's time to get serious
position yourself between these two
large rock outcroppings on your mark get
set go no seriously go run your best
chance to sneak past the first Gorgon
and snag that loot is to book it along
the right wall so book it okay that
didn't work out no matter just respawn
and book it again do this until it works
maybe work in a brief pause to let the
Gorgon patrol on past but mostly just
book it doesn't matter if you die once
you crack the chest because you'll keep
your loot and be able to start the next
run of fresh Oh Gorgons yeah there are
these weird glowing harpies and if they
see you your whole team gets the Gorgons
gaze and dies they can hear you move
they hate it when you run and they're a
bunch of them fortunately there's an
easy route through this labyrinth from
the start just go straight and kind of
leftish until you see the first Gorgon
follow it in crouch walk until it turns
right and then run over this big rock
and keep on running until you see this
even bigger rock with a blue flame hug
the right wall still running scoot into
this illuminated chamber and follow the
tunnel all the way to this ledge
congrats you survived the labyrinth and
you didn't even have to use your ball of
string now it's time to kick it Mario
styles and do some platforming
disappearing blocks that you have to
time your jumps to no problem especially
when the spawn point is right back at
this ledge hippity-hop your way over to
that far ledge then make your way around
it
just jump around this little crumbly bit
that'll send you into the abyss and
voila you've made it to a Theon's
doorstep hooray now prepare to get your
ass kicked next up on the final episode
of GameSpot stupendous destiny raid
guide extravaganza you've made it to the
inner sanctum of a real bad robot thingy
now it's time to kill a real bad robot
thingy and get paid